Sal: What I want to do in
this video is talk a little
bit about the curly
arrow conventions used in
organic chemistry and the
slight variations I use
in many of the videos
here on Khan Academy.
There's two types of
curly arrows you will see.
You will see a curly full arrow like this,
a curly full arrow like this.
And I make sure to draw it curly,
you will always see the curly like this.
And you will see a curly half
arrow that looks like this,
curly half arrow or fish hook arrow.
The convention is a full
arrow or a typical arrow
that you're used to
seeing, this is talking
about the movement of
pairs, of electron pairs.
Movement of pairs is the convention.
I'll show you in a second
that I do a slight variation
of that, and I do that
because it helps me account
for electrons, and it
helps me at least visualize
or conceptualize how
things are, or essentially
how things are happening,
a little bit better.
The general convention is
that this is movement of
pairs and this is movement
of electron by itself.
Electron, electron not part,
electron by itself, maybe
I'll write it this way.
By itself.
The full arrow is what you're going to
see through most of organic chemistry.
This is the one that you're going to
see most typically, the movement of pairs.
The movement of electrons
by itself, this is going to
show up more in free radical
reactions, which we do do,
but this is later on, and
most of organic chemistry
is going to be dealing
with the movement of pairs.
What I've drawn over here is a curly
arrow showing the same thing happening.
I'm showing you the slight
variation that I do.
I do it because it helps me, once again,
account for the electrons, and it helps
me conceptualize what is going on.
The typical way that this type
of mechanism will be shown,
we'll say you have this
electron pair on this oxygen,
and this electron pair,
sometimes we will say,
and you will learn about this
reaction in not too long,
is going to the carbon,
or I guess you could say
it's attacking the carbon right over here.
The reason why this I find
a little bit less intuitive
is that the whole pair is
not going to the carbon,
that the oxygen is still
going to maintain half
of this pair and it's
going to form a bond.
Essentially one end of this
pair is going to end up at
the carbon, one end of this
pair is going to end up
at the oxygen, and they
are going to form a bond.
The way I draw it, still
drawing the full arrow.
Here I'm still talking
about pairs but I'm talking
about the movement of an
electron as part of a pair.
That's kind of the slight non-conventional
thing that I do with the full arrow.
Movement, movement of electron,
electron as part of pair.
I'll often times draw the back
of the arrow from that electron,
but It's important to recognize
that electron is not moving
by itself, it's just ending
up on one side of a bond,
it is moving as part of a pair.
Another way to think of
it is this electron is
going to be on the other side of the bond.
I also want to be clear again.
When I talk about electrons
on either side of bonds,
I like to think about that because it
helps me do it for accounting purposes.
We know that these covalent
bonds, this one electron just
doesn't sit on one side of a
bond and the other electron
doesn't just sit on the
other side of the bond.
In fact everything we do
in organic chemistry isn't
anywhere near as clean as
the way we draw it, but I do
this to remind myself that
there are two electrons here,
and when you have a bond
there is some probability
that one of the electrons
is closer to the hydrogen
and there's some probability
that that electron is
closer to the carbon, and
so you can kind of imagine
that there are electrons on
either sides of the bond.
The actual reality is that
there's a blur over them and
depending on which molecule
is more electronegative
the probability blur is a
little bit more weighted on
one side or another, but
of course we like to clean
things up with these
formalisms right over here.
This is kind of the example
when you have this attacking
pair, why I like to
think of the full arrow
as the movement of an
electron as part of a pair.
And this breaking bond over
here is another example.
In the typical convention
you have this bond here.
Remember a bond is made up
of two, this covalent bond
right over here is made
up of two electrons.
If they wanted to show this
bond breaking and both of
these electrons going to
this bromine, the convention
is to go from the middle
of the bond to the bromine.
That I've never found that
intuitive because here,
once again, bromine already
essentially had part of
the bond, it was already
on one end of the bond.
I like to visualize that it's
getting the other electron
that it wasn't, it's now
getting both electrons.
One part of the bond was
already closer to the bromine,
now it's getting the other,
it's the other part of the bond.
We're going to use full
arrows for these mechanisms,
just as we would typically use
full arrows, but I'll often
conceptualize it as the movement
of an electron as part of
a pair, as opposed to the
entire pair, but the full arrows
are still used the way it
would be conventionally used.
Later on when we do free
radical reactions we're
going to talk about an
electron moving by itself.
Notice this electron right
over here, it's moving or
it's doing something and
it's not part of a pair,
it's by itself so we use
the fish hook arrows.
Right over here we see a
bond breaking but instead
of both electrons going
to one of the atoms or
another one of the atoms,
as right over here.
When both electrons went to one
of the atoms we use the full
arrow, this already you can say
had one and now it's gaining
another one so use the full
arrow, but here the bond is
breaking and each electron
is going to a different atom.
Once again the electron is moving,
the electron is moving by itself.
Maybe I'll put this
right, moving by itself,
and here is a movement of the
electron as part of a pair.
Hopefully that clarifies it a little bit.
It's important to keep in
mind a lot of the notation
I use is a departure from
the traditional organic
chemistry notation, but I
think at least in my mind it's
helped me build more of an
intuition of what's going
on in the mechanisms and
account for the electrons.
If you're in a course, and
especially depending on how it's
graded, you might want to
stick to whatever the professor
uses, which is probably going
to be a little bit closer to
the using the full arrow as
the whole pair, and going from
the middle of the bonds, the
middle of the pairs, as opposed
from one of the electrons
moving as part of the pair.